Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in a learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good
你好，我是马克斯，在西约克郡的一家学习障碍服务机构担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个最终目标，我开始研究目前有哪些资源，看看哪些书对我有帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，并决定买下它，这对我的职业旅程大有裨益。我觉得玛丽安的书非常有启发性，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你具备良好的
interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Professor Paul Gilbert OBE is one of the most influential psychologists of our time. And today I have the absolute privilege of speaking with him. In this episode, he shares lessons from a lifetime of work on compassion, shame, failure and success, and what they mean for us right now as psychologists and for the next generation of psychologist too. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. And if you like this content,
人际交往能力，比如同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想多了解临床心理学世界的人，正是这本书让我渴望有一天能在这个领域工作。保罗·吉尔伯特教授（OBE）是我们这个时代最有影响力的心理学家之一。今天，我有幸采访他。在这一集中，他分享了他在同情心、羞耻感、失败与成功方面毕生的研究心得，以及这些对于我们当下的心理学家和下一代心理学家意味着什么。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你喜欢这些内容，
subscribe, comment, share, do all those good things. And I hope you love it as much as I do. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am thrilled to be joined today by our guest, Professor Paul Gilbert OBE. Welcome, Paul. Well, thank you so much, Marianne, for inviting me. Well, thank you for saying yes, because I know you're a very busy man. And I thought, firstly, today, I'd really love to talk to you about psychology career. And during this episode, celebrating 200 episodes of the aspiring psychologist podcast, I'd really love to, I guess, firstly, thank you because I discovered your book, the compassionate mind, the big yellowy orange one in 2018 after my dad had died.
请订阅、评论、分享，做所有这些有益的事情。希望你像我一样喜欢它。你好，欢迎来到“有志心理学家播客”。今天我非常激动能邀请到我们的嘉宾，保罗·吉尔伯特教授（OBE）。欢迎你，保罗。谢谢你，玛丽安，邀请我来。谢谢你答应邀请，因为我知道你非常忙。今天，首先我想和你聊聊心理学职业。在这一集里，我们庆祝“有志心理学家播客”开播200期，我想首先感谢你，因为我在2018年父亲去世后发现了你的书《同情心思维》（那本大大的黄橙色的书）。
But I had this sliding doors moment where I could have discovered it sooner. So at that stage, I was in my doctorate for clinical psychology, and there was a number of books on a sideboard at a kind of a gathering we'd had. And one of my cohort had said, does anyone want to borrow any of these books? And I know that's an author's worst nightmare that these books are all being shared around, and we get no royalties. And I looked at it, and I saw the size of it, I have to say, Paul. And I was like, no, no, no, thanks. But actually when I then had the time to listen to it in 2018, when I think I needed it most, I was like, what if I had to pick that up in 2010?
但我当时错过了一个机会，本可以更早发现它的。那时我正在攻读临床心理学博士学位，在一次聚会上，餐具柜上放着几本书。我的一位同学问：“有人想借这些书看吗？”我知道这是作者最不想看到的，书被传来传去，却拿不到版税。我看了看那本书，说实话，保罗，我看到它的厚度，就说：“不，不，不，谢谢。”但实际上，当我在2018年有时间去听它时，正是我最需要它的时候，我心想：如果我在2010年就读了它会怎样？
How might that have helped me to go through training more compassionately, to be pregnant and to birth my children and kind of have them when they were younger and support me in my relationships and in grief and all of that stuff? And I just wanted to say, thank you for what you do, for me, but also, you know, the world, really, and the psychology community, because it really matters. So thank you. How wonderful is that? Okay, I think I'll stop at this point. That's just wonderful.
那会如何帮助我更具同情心地完成学业，怀孕生子，在孩子还小的时候照顾他们，并在人际关系和悲伤中支持我，以及所有这些事情？我只是想说，谢谢你所做的一切，不仅是为了我，也是为了这个世界，为了心理学界，因为这真的很重要。所以，谢谢你。这太棒了。好吧，我想我就说到这里。这真是太棒了。
Yeah, but like, even this podcast has been so informed by you and your work. You know, I thought, well, if we could have a compassionate voice, guiding to you. people through their career. And I was in the position when I was 22, 23, I would say I was working in Milton Keynes Council doing some work with physically disabled adults. I didn't know any clinical psychologists at the time. And obviously the internet was around, but it was very different and podcasts weren't really a thing at all, I think, at that stage. And I thought, what if people have the competences and the capabilities to develop into a really great, you know, HCPC psych one day, but they don't currently, they can't currently getting the room to be having
是的，甚至这个播客也深受你和你工作的影响。我想，如果我们能有一个充满同情心的声音，引导人们走过他们的职业生涯。我22、23岁时，在米尔顿凯恩斯议会工作，为残疾成年人提供服务。当时我不认识任何临床心理学家。显然那时互联网已经存在，但情况非常不同，播客在当时根本不算什么。我心想，如果人们有能力和潜力在未来成为一名优秀的HCPC注册心理学家，但他们目前无法进入那个环境去进行
those conversations or to be able to expand their knowledge or to tune in to, you know, the mighty Paul Gilbert. So that's why the podcast was born to be able to kind of level the playing field a little bit, but also to up the compassion in this, in this career. Well, that's wonderful. And congratulations on 200 episodes. That's amazing. That's an amazing amount of work and effort. Thank you. Yeah, it is. And it's 200 weeks. So it's a, it's been a weekly podcast because I fear that if I ever, I've had a week off, I wouldn't want to go back because I'd realize how nice it is to have a little bit more time. But I'm passionate about it and I'm passionate about the people who listen to it and to value it. So let's, let's think a little bit about you and your career, Paul. Tell us about, tell us about you and what kind of brought you to where we are now. Well, it's a slightly interesting career because originally I always wanted to be a psychologist in the 60s, but in those days they said, oh, no, psychology is not much of a career for you. And I was studying economics. They said, no, yeah, that would be much better for you. So I did do that. I got a degree in economics. But while I was going through, I was also reading a psychology books and think, no, I want to do that. And in those days, you could do changeover courses. And so I did a changeover course. What that meant is that they would take people with other degrees, and then you could do an MSC and psychology, it's experimental psychology. Fast track it. It was very intense course. So I went down to Sussex in 73, 74, and did the MSC down there.
那些对话，或者无法扩展他们的知识，或者无法收听像伟大的保罗·吉尔伯特这样的专家的见解。这就是播客诞生的原因，为了在一定程度上创造公平的竞争环境，同时也为了在这个职业中提升同情心。太棒了，祝贺你达到200期。这太了不起了。这是令人惊叹的工作量和努力。谢谢。是的，确实。而且是200周。这是一个每周更新的播客，因为我担心如果我休息一周，我就不想再回来了，因为我会意识到拥有更多时间是多么美好。但我对它充满热情，我也对那些收听并重视它的人充满热情。那么，让我们来谈谈你和你的职业生涯，保罗。告诉我们关于你的一切，以及是什么让你走到了今天。嗯，这是一个有趣的职业生涯，因为最初在60年代，我一直想成为一名心理学家，但当时他们说：“哦，不，心理学对你来说不是什么好职业。”我当时在学经济学。他们说：“不，是的，那对你来说会好得多。”所以我确实那样做了。我获得了经济学学位。但在学习过程中，我一直在读心理学书籍，心想：“不，我想做那个。”在那个年代，你可以参加转专业课程。所以我参加了一个转专业课程。这意味着他们会招收拥有其他学位的学生，然后你可以攻读心理学硕士学位，即实验心理学。这是一个快车道，课程非常紧张。所以我1973年、1974年去了萨塞克斯大学，在那里完成了硕士学位。
Now, it turned out I wasn't very good at neurophysiology, so I failed my neurophysiology and had to stay there for another year. So I needed some money. So I went and worked as a night nurse and a psychiatric and acute unit in. writing and that was interesting because in those days we used to have all the young people coming down from London and taking loads of drugs on Brighton Beach and then ending up as our guests because they'd sort of lost it a bit so it was very interesting I learned to an awful lot doing that year on acute psychiatry I always wanted to be a clinician so I studied very hard neurophysiology and managed to pass obviously and then
结果我发现我不擅长神经生理学，所以我挂科了，不得不留在那里多待一年。所以我需要钱。于是我去了一家精神科急诊病房当夜班护士。那很有趣，因为在那个年代，我们经常有年轻人从伦敦下来，在布莱顿海滩吸食大量毒品，然后成了我们的“客人”，因为他们有点失控了。所以那一年在急诊精神科的工作让我学到了很多，非常有趣。我一直想成为一名临床医生，所以我非常努力地学习神经生理学，显然最后通过了。然后
set off and I started off in Birmingham, but we then went to Edinburgh. I went to an Emberra MRC unit and that was good for me because I was on an acute ward. Again, we used to take people from all over Scotland with chronic depression and so I had a little office on the ward and the Prof Ashcroft, who was the professor of psychiatry, lovely man, it's long, long passed away now. So look, the best way to understand depression is to go and talk to repress people and you've got lots of them here. So I used to do that is to go on to the ward and go around chat to people and learn a lot about stories and part of the themes that came out of that was obviously the history of abuse that was one thing genetic vulnerability was another thing and also the sense of defeat and entrapment and lossness that shunned through those people's experience and for those who know my research that became a big issue of looking at issues of feelings of social defeat and entrapment and so on and it's been a big series of studies on that now so So they got the PhD and oh, by the way, well, I was in Brighton, the one year I met my beloved
我出发了，最初在伯明翰，但后来我们去了爱丁堡。我去了爱丁堡的MRC（医学研究委员会）部门，这对我有好处，因为我在一个急诊病房。我们经常接收来自苏格兰各地患有慢性抑郁症的病人，所以我在病房里有一个小办公室。阿什克罗夫特教授，精神病学教授，一位可爱的人，现在已经去世很久了。他说：“看，了解抑郁症的最好方法就是去和抑郁的人交谈，这里有很多这样的人。”所以我经常这样做，去病房和人们聊天，了解了很多故事。其中出现的主题显然包括虐待史，这是一个方面；遗传易感性是另一个方面；还有那些人经历中流露出的挫败感、被困感和失落感。对于那些了解我研究的人来说，这成为了一个大课题，即研究社会挫败感和被困感等问题，现在已经有一系列关于此的研究了。所以他们获得了博士学位。哦，顺便说一下，我在布莱顿的那一年，遇到了我挚爱的妻子，因为我当时为大学打板球，她负责记分，那真的很不错，不是吗？从那以后我们一直在一起。所以我们搬到了爱丁堡。爱丁堡的特别之处在于，因为它是一个MRC部门，他们都在做药物研究等等。如果你不懂神经生理学，午餐时你就没有朋友。所以所有的精神科医生都会说：“哦，你知道，抑郁症完全与大脑中的这些受体有关。”我说：“是的，这很重要，但它们难道不是由心理和社会过程创造的吗？”
because I used to play cricket for the university and she used to keep the score, so that was nice, wasn't it really? And we've been together ever since. So we toddled off to Edinburgh and the thing about Edinburgh was because it was an MRC unit, they were all doing these studies on drugs and everything. If you didn't understand neurophysiology, you didn't have any friends at lunch. So I'd have all these psychiatrists say, oh, you know, depression is all to do with these receptors in the brain. And I said, yes, that's important, but could they all be created by psychological and social processes?
（注：此处原文音频与文本略有重叠，已根据上下文逻辑翻译）
So my first book was called Depression from Psychology to Brain State in 1984. And that was really arguing the ways of which psychological and social processes can have major impacts on the brain. And in 75, Martin Selwyn came out with his book and Helpless and showing these massive changes in physiology when people are confronted with uncontrollable stresses. And that's really quite important because, as you know, we have a biosyncosocial process. When you're working with depressed patients,
所以我的第一本书是1984年出版的《抑郁症：从心理学到大脑状态》。那本书实际上是在论证心理和社会过程如何对大脑产生重大影响。1975年，马丁·塞利格曼出版了他的书《习得性无助》，展示了当人们面对无法控制的压力时，生理上会发生巨大的变化。这非常重要，因为如你所知，我们有一个生物-心理-社会过程。当你与抑郁症患者一起工作时，
they feel really ill. I mean, physiologically, they're not well. Then that doesn't mean to say they have an endogenous illness, but they are really not well. And the sleep cycles off, the circadian rhythms off, dopamine systems have pretty much collapsed for some of the severe depressions. It was always important to keep in mind that you're not just dealing with negative schemers or beliefs or whatever, but actually dealing with somebody whose brain and body
他们感觉真的很糟糕。我的意思是，从生理上讲，他们并不健康。这并不意味着他们患有内源性疾病，但他们确实很不舒服。睡眠周期紊乱，昼夜节律失调，多巴胺系统在一些严重的抑郁症中几乎崩溃了。始终记住这一点很重要：你处理的不仅仅是消极的图式或信念，而是正在处理一个大脑和身体
have kind of been affected by the depression, and therefore you're going to need a therapy that's going to have some kind of physiological effect. So that was always sort of in my mind, really. So that was – then I was decided I wanted to be a researcher. I was going to go to Stanford. And my beloved and I got married on the basis of that, because we were living together together. And that was fine. And they said, in Edinburgh, they said, oh, no, STEM, do the clinical training.
已经被抑郁症影响的人，因此你需要一种能产生某种生理影响的疗法。所以这始终在我的脑海里。后来我决定想成为一名研究员。我打算去斯坦福大学。我和我挚爱的妻子因此结婚了，因为我们当时住在一起。这很好。在爱丁堡，他们说：“哦，不，留下来，完成临床培训。”
I said, no, I go to Stanford, don't you do? But when I was just about to go, I had a letter to say there'd been a complication with the department, the department was on some kind of investigation. So they couldn't honor the job. Nowadays, of course, I'd sue them. But in those days, I just sort of wandered off with my leg, a tail between my legs. But luckily, I managed to get a place on a clinical course in Norwich. So in 1978, we headed down to Norwich,
我说：“不，我要去斯坦福，你们不也是吗？”但就在我准备走的时候，我收到一封信，说部门出了点问题，部门正在接受某种调查。所以他们无法兑现那个职位。如今，我当然会起诉他们。但在那个年代，我只是夹着尾巴灰溜溜地走了。但幸运的是，我设法在诺里奇的一个临床课程中获得了一个名额。所以1978年，我们前往诺里奇，
and I became, started to train as a clinical psychologist with the, what was then the BPS diploma. And so that's how I got into clinical psychology by various routes. The interesting thing about economics was economics was always about building models. So you had to, in the first year, you'd understand some unemployment and the terms of trade and how the money supply works. And then the second year, you start to see how economies work and so on. When I got to psychology, it was odd because you'd have a course on motivation, a course
我开始接受临床心理学家的培训，获得了当时的英国心理学会（BPS）文凭。这就是我通过各种途径进入临床心理学领域的方式。经济学有趣的地方在于，经济学总是关于建立模型。所以你在第一年必须理解一些失业、贸易条件和货币供应量是如何运作的。然后第二年，你开始看到经济是如何运作的等等。当我进入心理学时，这很奇怪，因为你会有一门关于动机的课程，一门
on child development, it was no integrated thinking at all. And when I said to people that were talking to me, it was training me, I said, well, what about an integrated model of the mind? How does these things all work together? And they kind of looks into in their beer and said, oh, no, that's too complicated, tap, tat. No, we don't do that. We just study these different bits. We're very scientific.
关于儿童发展的课程，根本没有任何综合性的思考。当我问那些教我的人时，我说：“那么，关于心灵的综合模型呢？这些东西是如何协同工作的？”他们看着他们的啤酒说：“哦，不，那太复杂了，别想了。不，我们不那样做。我们只是研究这些不同的部分。我们非常科学。”
We're going to study language. We study language. We don't think about how language affects motivation. So I thought, well, in order for us to have models about how and why people become mentally and mental health difficulties or what we can do, we need to understand how the mind works as a system, right? So you need to understand. So where you look at compassion focus therapy, which we'll talk about a little bit later, you'll find that really it's rooted in all the basic psychological sciences.
“我们要研究语言，我们就研究语言。我们不去想语言如何影响动机。”所以我认为，为了让我们拥有关于人们为何会产生心理健康困难或我们能做些什么的模型，我们需要了解心灵作为一个系统是如何工作的，对吧？所以你需要了解。当你看到同情心聚焦疗法（CFT）时，我们稍后会谈到，你会发现它实际上植根于所有基础心理科学。
And that's why I think psychologists in particularly like them, because we don't root it in cognitive systems or motivational systems. You need to think about all of those. So if you look at the standard psychology textbook, which you would have done in your undergraduate days, there is a whole literature on motives and how motives were. There's a whole literature on emotions, and there's a whole literature on cognitive processes, problem solving, mind, and so that's the problem is when people turn up, clinical psychologists turn up for training. They've kind of forgotten all that. And so they're just trying to work in a model, you know, a CBT model or a DBT model or KGB model, whatever it is. They're trying to fit all these complicated processes into a single model, and they simply won't fit. And that's why. we are not as forward, I believe, in our psychological therapies as we could be.
这就是为什么我认为心理学家特别喜欢它，因为我们不把它仅仅根植于认知系统或动机系统。你需要考虑所有这些。所以如果你看标准的心理学教科书，你在本科时代读过的那种，里面有关于动机及其运作方式的完整文献。有关于情绪的完整文献，还有关于认知过程、解决问题、思维的完整文献。这就是问题所在，当人们出现时，临床心理学家出现接受培训时。他们已经忘记了所有这些。所以他们只是试图在一个模型中工作，你知道，一个CBT（认知行为疗法）模型，或者一个DBT（辩证行为疗法）模型，或者KGB模型，无论是什么。他们试图把所有这些复杂的流程塞进一个单一的模型中，它们根本塞不进去。这就是为什么
Now, a lot of the models are getting much more biosecocial. They're beginning to understand that you need interventions that are going to have physiological effects and social effects and so on and so on. But I think if you're aspiring psychologists, bring your psychological science to what you're doing. Don't get trapped up in one of these schools of therapy. They're very useful, and they have a lot of things to. say about interventions and so on but always stay a psychologist right don't label yourself or think
我们认为我们的心理疗法还没有达到应有的水平。现在，许多模型正变得越来越生物-心理-社会化。他们开始明白，你需要产生生理影响和社会影响的干预措施等等。但我认为，如果你是有志于成为心理学家的人，请把你所做的心理科学带入你的工作中。不要被困在这些疗法流派中的某一个里。它们非常有用，在干预措施等方面有很多话要说，但始终保持心理学家的身份，对吧？不要给自己贴标签，或者认为
of yourself as a CBT therapist or a psychodynamic therapist or emotion focus therapy or a body-based therapist all of those approaches have fantastic wisdoms for intervention but when it comes to thinking about what are we dealing with here what how are bodies and minds working then you are the best position you are the best profession because you're the one that has studied the mind. You're the one that studying motivations and emotions and so forth. And so you can bring your own wisdoms into what you're doing. So we're very keen on that, that psychologists don't sort of get caught up and just being this type of therapist or that type of therapist, be a psychologist that learns how to use those interventions, but put it within a conceptually scientific model
自己是一个CBT治疗师，或者心理动力学治疗师，或者情绪聚焦治疗师，或者身体导向治疗师。所有这些方法都有奇妙的干预智慧，但当谈到思考“我们在这里处理什么”、“身体和心灵是如何运作的”时，你是处于最佳位置的，你是最好的职业，因为你是研究心灵的人。你是研究动机和情绪等等的人。所以你可以把你自己的智慧带入你所做的事情中。所以我们非常热衷于这一点，即心理学家不要被困在仅仅成为这种类型的治疗师或那种类型的治疗师，要做一个学习如何使用这些干预措施的心理学家，但要把它放在一个概念性的科学模型中
of the mind. Amazing. That's so interesting and so helpful. Could you give us almost like a practical example of what that might look like. If someone finds themselves in a ward round and they're thinking, I don't feel like there's a very psychological conversation happening about this person or this kind of set of circumstances that we're talking about, how could someone use their psychological underpinnings and insights to just have a different conversation in that room pool? Yeah, well, it depends. You see, for example, if you're working with somebody who's hearing voice, if you're in a acute, you're hearing with somebody's hearing voices, you say, Well, from a psychological point of view, we need to understand, is the trauma in this person's background?
来理解心灵。太棒了。这太有趣也太有帮助了。你能给我们一个实际的例子，说明那看起来是什么样的吗？如果有人发现自己参加查房，他们心想：“我觉得关于这个人或我们正在讨论的这组情况，并没有进行非常心理学的对话。”一个人如何利用他们的心理学基础和洞察力，在那个房间里进行一场不同的对话呢，保罗？是的，嗯，这取决于情况。你看，例如，如果你正在和听到声音的人一起工作，如果你在急诊病房，你正在和听到声音的人一起工作，你会说：“嗯，从心理学的角度来看，我们需要了解，这个人的背景中是否有创伤？”
We need to understand what the, are there certain triggers of these voices? And if we listen to these voices, are they telling us something about motivations or underlying fears? So the great thing about a psychologist is you think psychologically. I mean, it may sound obvious, but actually it isn't. And when you're in a ward round, what other people are thinking about medications or symptom profiles or the regular. or symptoms, whatever. You're thinking of the person living with a mind in their context and their history. All of that is really part of what makes that person have the experience that they're having. And that sometimes with people who have very severe mental health problems,
我们需要了解，这些声音是否有特定的触发因素？如果我们倾听这些声音，它们是否在告诉我们关于动机或潜在恐惧的事情？所以心理学家的伟大之处在于你从心理学角度思考。我的意思是，这听起来可能很明显，但实际上并非如此。当你查房时，其他人可能在考虑药物、症状概况或常规症状等等。而你正在考虑的是一个在他们的背景和历史中带着心灵生活的人。所有这些确实是导致那个人产生他们所经历的体验的一部分。有时对于那些有非常严重心理健康问题的人来说，
you know, unprocessed trauma is really quite important. And it was quite late. I think it was only in the 80s, actually, that people started to recognize that a lot of these mental health problems that we work with they're sitting on a sea of trauma and if you don't deal with that trauma then they're going to have relapse after relapse after relapse so thinking psychologically as a psychologist that's what you're bringing to your ward round you're there to think as a psychologist you know the psychiatrist is thinking in terms of drugs or whatever and some of the good ones will also think in terms of psychology of course but you're there to really talk about do we know about this Do we know anything about their background?
未处理的创伤确实非常重要。我想直到80年代，人们才开始认识到，我们所处理的许多心理健康问题都建立在创伤的海洋之上，如果你不处理那个创伤，那么他们就会一次又一次地复发。所以作为一名心理学家，从心理学角度思考，这就是你带给查房的内容。你在那里是为了像心理学家一样思考，你知道，精神科医生在考虑药物或类似的东西，当然，一些优秀的医生也会考虑心理学，但你在那里是为了真正讨论：我们了解这个吗？我们了解他们的背景吗？
Do we know what their triggers are? Do we know how they deal with their triggers? Do we know how we can help and cope with the triggers? Do we know how we can help them? If they're hearing voices, hostile voices, do we have been able to teach them ways in which they can learn to work with those voices and so on and so on? So you're bringing your psychological knowledge into the world around.
我们知道他们的触发因素是什么吗？我们知道他们如何处理触发因素吗？我们知道我们如何能帮助他们应对触发因素吗？我们知道我们如何能帮助他们吗？如果他们听到声音，敌对的声音，我们是否能够教他们学习如何与这些声音共处的方法等等。所以你正在把你的心理学知识带入查房中。
Absolutely. And I guess just trying to really help bring forward that idea of a formulation actually, you know, and I think that can be so helpful and I'll often think about longitudinal formulation or just, yeah, like what has been, if we're weaving in compassion, what has been their experience of how they've been spoken to and how they might then have internalized how they should speak to themselves and how it's okay to treat other people. Like, so interesting. I mean, the classic position, sorry, don't know you, but the classic position I think is it's not
绝对是这样。我想，只是试图真正帮助推进那个“构思”（formulation）的概念，你知道，我认为这非常有帮助。我经常会考虑纵向构思，或者只是，是的，如果我们将同情心编织进去，他们被对待的方式的经历是什么，他们可能随后内化了他们应该如何对自己说话，以及如何对待他人是可以接受的。这太有趣了。我的意思是，经典的立场，抱歉，我不认识你，但我认为经典的立场是：不是
what's wrong with you, it's what's happened to you. psychologist has what's happened to you, how you, as opposed to what's wrong with you. Yeah, and there's a very big shift. And I think even when we look at individual families, you know, the same parents, the same house even that children have been born into can still lead to very different outcomes for that child because, of course, time has changed those parents. Time has changed the world in between those siblings being born. You know, I think I was a very different parent for my first baby than I was for my second just because of life circumstances and, I don't know, the way that I felt about the world.
“你有什么问题”，而是“你经历了什么”。心理学家关注的是“你经历了什么”，而不是“你有什么问题”。是的，这是一个非常大的转变。我认为即使当我们观察个别家庭时，你知道，同一个父母，同一个孩子出生的房子，仍然可能导致那个孩子非常不同的结果，因为当然，时间改变了那些父母。在那些兄弟姐妹出生之间，时间改变了世界。你知道，我想我对我第一个孩子的教育方式和我对第二个孩子的教育方式非常不同，仅仅是因为生活环境，以及，我不知道，我对世界的感受。
And my dad was very well, very healthy when I was pregnant with my eldest. But by the time my second came along, he'd been diagnosed with cancer. So my kind of hope and availability was very different for both of those babies. And so I think sometimes just thinking about context, yeah, and what has been that child's experience, but what has been their family's experience can be really helpful as well. Very much, so, very much so. And also, children are themselves. Anna Freud would say babies are themselves, right?
当我怀着长子时，我父亲身体非常好，非常健康。但当第二个孩子出生时，他被诊断出患有癌症。所以我对这两个孩子的希望和陪伴是非常不同的。所以我认为有时仅仅思考背景，是的，以及那个孩子的经历是什么，但他们的家庭经历是什么，也会非常有帮助。非常如此，非常如此。而且，孩子们本身就是独立的个体。安娜·弗洛伊德会说婴儿本身就是独立的，对吧？
They're not all clients. They're not exact clients. They all have different personalities, different needs. They relate in different ways. You know, very active children relate to passive mothers, very different to shy children, for example. So you're absolutely right about that. I mean, it's very important. The individual difference is extremely important
他们不是完全一样的客户。他们不是精确的客户。他们都有不同的个性，不同的需求。他们以不同的方式建立联系。你知道，非常活跃的孩子与被动的母亲建立联系的方式，与害羞的孩子完全不同。所以你关于这一点是绝对正确的。我的意思是，这非常重要。个体差异在临床心理学中极其重要。
in clinical psychology. It really is. And I want to thank you for something you said earlier as well, which was really important, kind of giving permission for scratching those itches that you're interested in. That's really important, even if you've been told, no, this would be better for you. Like, you should do this, but giving us a permission
确实如此。我想感谢你刚才说的另一件事，这非常重要，即给予许可去探索你感兴趣的那些领域。这非常重要，即使你被告知：“不，这对你来说会更好。”比如，你应该做这个，但给予我们许可
to come back to it. But also role modeling that actually, even when we get to become clinical psychologists, we may well have failed things along the way. I certainly failed my first attempt at a probability module when I was at university. You know, you failed your kind of first attempt at the kind of biophysiology, I think you said.
回到它。而且还要以身作则，实际上，即使我们成为临床心理学家，我们也可能在过程中失败过。我当然在大学时第一次尝试概率模块时失败了。你知道，我想你说过，你在生物生理学方面的第一次尝试也失败了。
Like it doesn't mean that you should give up, does it? No, no, no, no, no. It's okay to have another go. Yeah, yeah. I got really good at it because I had a whole year just to do it. Okay, so there might almost be that, that post-traumatic growth about what happens when we give ourselves more time and have
这并不意味着你应该放弃，对吧？不，不，不，不。再试一次是可以的。是的，是的。我变得非常擅长它，因为我有一整年的时间专门做这件事。好吧，所以这几乎可能是一种创伤后成长，关于当我们给自己更多时间并以更专注的方式
another go in a more focused way. I think that's a really crucial point, isn't it? The secret of success is the ability to fail. We often used to say that to the clients, you know, but no, you've got to help you succeed. No, I'm going to help you fail because if you can fail, you'll keep going when you fail and you'll get better. So that's a very important point you make, Marianne. Yeah, it really is. And it, you know, absolutely. And I think, especially, when we're told, you know, what actually first, I only decided to become a clinical psychologist in the very end weeks of my undergraduate degree. And I don't know what it says about me that this was what piqued my interest, was that I was told from a clinical psychologist standing on a stage
再试一次时会发生什么。我认为这是一个非常关键的点，不是吗？成功的秘诀是失败的能力。我们过去经常对客户说：“不，你必须帮助你成功。”不，我要帮助你失败，因为如果你能失败，你就会在失败时继续前进，你会变得更好。所以这是一个非常重要的点，玛丽安。是的，确实如此。而且，你知道，绝对是这样。而且我认为，特别是当我们被告知，你知道，实际上我直到本科学习的最后几周才决定成为一名临床心理学家。我不知道这说明了我什么，是什么激起了我的兴趣，是因为我被一位站在舞台上的临床心理学家告知：
is a really hard career. I wouldn't recommend you to try. It's not a great narrative, isn't it? It is true. And actually, I'm so glad I did try. Well, I did try. try because I genuinely love what I do. I love the variety of my work. And I just don't, I don't get that sense in the same way of, oh, I've got to do that thing or I've got to do that session. Like, I get, I get to do this. I genuinely feel that's, that's how I feel about my work. And I know not everyone feels like that about, about their jobs and their occupation. So I feel really fortunate that I do. Yes, it's a great point. I mean, I mean, you know, the fact that you might not always enjoy it doesn't mean to say that you don't want to do it, right? Because it's different types of positive emotion, isn't there? One of which is about the positive emotion we get from doing meaningful things. So like changing your baby's nappies and things that might not be so pleasant. But it's meaningful, all right? We do things not because they're pleasant, but because they're meaningful. They give us a sense of purpose and so on. So that's a very important.
“这是一个非常艰难的职业。我不建议你尝试。”这不是一个很好的叙述，不是吗？这是真的。而且我很高兴我确实尝试了。我确实尝试了，因为我真心热爱我所做的事情。我热爱我工作的多样性。我只是没有那种感觉，比如“哦，我必须做那件事”或“我必须做那个疗程”。就像，我“有机会”做这个。我真心觉得这就是我对工作的感受。我知道并不是每个人都对他们的工作和职业有这种感觉。所以我感到非常幸运，我确实有。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我的意思是，我的意思是，你知道，你可能并不总是享受它，这并不意味着你不想做它，对吧？因为有不同类型的积极情绪，不是吗？其中之一是关于我们从做有意义的事情中获得的积极情绪。就像给你的宝宝换尿布之类的事情可能并不那么令人愉快。但它是有意义的，对吧？我们做事情不是因为它们令人愉快，而是因为它们有意义。它们给了我们目标感等等。所以这是一个非常重要的
point you make that if we're just you know yes it is a very hard career and I think sometimes it's a when you're faced with all the tragedies of life day and day out it can get a bit tricky at times but it's meaningful you wouldn't give it up you know you still want to do that yeah and and with that in mind like you've kind of alluded to the what's happening in the world at the moment it feels challenging as a mother it feels challenging as as just a human it feels challenging as a clinical psychologist and you know with the rise of AI as well it's it's just a difficult it's just a difficult time and maybe you know you have more more years and more wisdom than me
点，你提到如果我们要只是……你知道，是的，这是一个非常艰难的职业，我认为有时当你面对生活中的所有悲剧时，日复一日，有时会变得有点棘手，但它是有意义的，你不会放弃它，你知道，你仍然想做那个。是的，考虑到这一点，就像你提到的目前世界上正在发生的事情，作为一名母亲，这感觉很有挑战性；作为一名人类，这感觉很有挑战性；作为一名临床心理学家，这感觉很有挑战性。而且，你知道，随着人工智能的兴起，这只是一个困难的时期，也许，你知道，你比我有更多的岁月和更多的智慧，
like has it has it always felt like we're living in the most difficult time right now or or is this especially challenging no no you're no it's not especially challenging in CFT with life is full of suffering life is very challenging I mean you know it wasn't so long ago we had the plague and something like half of the population was killed off right so we've always been confronted with diseases and violence wars and so on poverty obviously a lot of humans have lived in intense poverty for many thousands of years and as you know we've lived in terrorist states mostly because with the evolution of agriculture we got the development of the aggressive male and the dominant of the elites so you look at the assyrians the egypt the Romans, all of them, they were all terrorist states, they would just persecute. 30% of the population in Rome were slaves, right? If you look at the reign of Henry VIII, thousands of people were hung in London for crimes that just stealing a loaf of bread, right? We forget all this because we're living,
就像，它是否一直感觉我们现在生活在最困难的时期，或者这特别具有挑战性？不，不，你不是……不，它并不特别具有挑战性。在CFT（同情心聚焦疗法）中，生活充满了苦难，生活非常有挑战性。我的意思是，你知道，不久前我们还有瘟疫，大约一半的人口被消灭了，对吧？所以我们一直面临着疾病、暴力、战争等等。贫困，显然许多人类几千年来一直生活在极度贫困中。而且如你所知，我们大多生活在恐怖国家，因为随着农业的发展，我们有了好斗的男性和精英的统治。所以你看看亚述人、埃及人、罗马人，他们所有人，他们都是恐怖国家，他们只会迫害。罗马30%的人口是奴隶，对吧？如果你看看亨利八世的统治，成千上万的人在伦敦因为仅仅偷了一块面包这样的罪行而被绞死，对吧？我们忘记了这一切，因为我们生活在，
we've gone through, we're going through periods where things are getting a lot better. Medicine does some miracle stuff now. You know, starvation is not common in Europe at least. I mean, it's been used as a weapon of war, obviously, which is horrible. So because things have been really good, we look at these things, oh, my God, everything's getting worse. It's nothing like it was a few hundred years ago. So that's important to see that on the whole, humans are improving.
我们经历过，我们正在经历事情变得好得多的时期。医学现在做了一些奇迹般的事情。你知道，饥饿在欧洲至少不常见。我的意思是，它显然被用作战争武器，这很可怕。所以因为事情一直很好，我们看着这些事情说：“哦，天哪，一切都在变糟。”它根本不像几百年前那样。所以看到这一点很重要，总的来说，人类正在进步。
The key area that we have to improve is not our technologies and our medicine, so we do need to improve that. It's our minds and how we choose our leaders. As it is at the moment, leadership is, the most damaging of all human things, right? The leaders that are getting to businesses of power, particularly these narcissistic and psychopathic. And we have to understand how do they get voted in? How do they get supported? Because it's the leaders that are actually causing so many difficulties. And it's also in like in the AI industries and the fossil industries, all of these
我们必须改进的关键领域不是我们的技术和医学，虽然我们确实需要改进这些。而是我们的心灵以及我们如何选择我们的领导者。目前的情况是，领导力是所有人类事物中最具破坏性的，对吧？那些进入权力职位的领导者，特别是这些自恋和精神病态的领导者。我们必须了解他们是如何被投票选出的？他们是如何得到支持的？因为正是领导者实际上造成了如此多的困难。而且在人工智能行业和化石燃料行业也是如此，所有这些
individuals, if they lack a compassion focus, then they're careless and they will cause mayhem. So it's not so much the process of change. It's who's in control of that process of change, which is the real kind of worry, I think, and it is a bit of a worry, but I'm not pessimistic because I think that there are sufficient numbers of people in the world who are, have a genuine compassion. Most people want to be compassionate, and if we can get the right leadership, then I think we can move the world to a more compassionate place. We could talk about that. We're doing a lot of work on that. So the key thing is don't lose hope.
个人，如果他们缺乏同情心，那么他们就是粗心的，他们会造成混乱。所以这与其说是变革的过程，不如说是谁在控制那个变革的过程，这才是真正的担忧，我认为，这确实有点令人担忧，但我并不悲观，因为我认为世界上有足够多的人拥有真正的同情心。大多数人想要有同情心，如果我们能得到正确的领导，那么我认为我们可以把世界推向一个更有同情心的地方。我们可以谈谈这个。我们正在为此做很多工作。所以关键是不要失去希望。
Yes, things are tricky and all kinds of conflicts going on and so on and so on. But our movement on diseases is getting better. We just had COVID and we evolved this amazing vaccine that actually saved millions. I mean, there would never have happened in any other part of history, but we're getting the technologies. And yes, the pharmaceutical companies were profits here and didn't give the vaccines to the developing countries and so on. But the key thing is that we can do it if we choose to do it. There are people now working in AI about how do you create a moral basis for AI. And that's really important because AI, if we don't, then AI will be problematic.
是的，事情很棘手，各种冲突正在发生等等。但我们在疾病方面的进展正在好转。我们刚刚经历了新冠疫情，我们研发了这种神奇的疫苗，实际上拯救了数百万人。我的意思是，这在历史上的任何其他时期都不会发生，但我们正在获得技术。是的，制药公司在这里追求利润，没有把疫苗给发展中国家等等。但关键是，如果我们选择这样做，我们就能做到。现在有人在人工智能领域工作，关于如何为人工智能创造道德基础。这非常重要，因为人工智能，如果我们不这样做，那么人工智能就会有问题。
So I think, you know, there are really good people in the world as well. And I always look to them rather than not so good people. So, yes, I'm kind of hopeful in the long term. But yes, life is suffering, and no doubt there will be more suffering ahead. And that's a really helpful reminder. Thank you. And I think that's one I'll keep drawing on for sure. Yeah, like it's, I think when we're looking at kind of what we can achieve within our career,
所以我认为，你知道，世界上也有非常好的人。我总是看向他们，而不是那些不太好的人。所以，是的，从长远来看，我有点充满希望。但是的，生活就是苦难，毫无疑问未来会有更多的苦难。这是一个非常有帮助的提醒。谢谢。我想这肯定是我会一直借鉴的一个提醒。是的，就像，我认为当我们审视我们在职业生涯中能取得什么成就时，
and it's fair to say you've achieved a great deal and they're still striving to achieve more. But when you're at the early part of a career, perhaps even still just considering becoming a psychologist, how do you not burn out when you see the challenges before you, with apparently mental health being worse than it ever has been, certainly in the UK, and the level of kind of dissatisfaction and poverty and trauma? How do you feel enough just as a drop in that ocean? Yes. Don't be narcissistic, basically. that's what's so I was a friend of Michael we talked about this from few years ago
公平地说，你已经取得了巨大的成就，并且仍在努力取得更多成就。但当你处于职业生涯的早期，甚至可能还在考虑成为一名心理学家时，当你看到面前的挑战时，如何不精疲力竭？心理健康状况似乎比以往任何时候都更糟，当然是在英国，以及那种不满、贫困和创伤的程度。当你只是那片海洋中的一滴水时，你如何感到足够？是的。基本上，不要自恋。这就是……所以我是迈克尔的朋友，我们几年前谈过这个，
because if you're doing that you're just assuming you've got or you should have more power than you don't there's a wonderful story it's a feminist story actually it's lovely the story so this guy and his girlfriend are walking along the beach and there's been a massive storm and all of these starfish are thrown up onto the beach there's thousands and thousands of them and as she's walking along she's picking one up and throwing it back And the guy says, so, what are you doing that for? I mean, there's thousands of them. And she said, because it matters to the one I throw back.
因为如果你那样做，你只是假设你拥有或者你应该拥有比你实际拥有的更多的权力。有一个精彩的故事，实际上是一个女权主义故事，它很可爱。故事是这样的：这个家伙和他的女朋友沿着海滩走，发生了一场巨大的风暴，所有的海星都被冲到了海滩上。有成千上万只。当她走着的时候，她捡起一只扔回海里。那个家伙说：“那么，你为什么要那样做？我的意思是，有成千上万只。”她说：“因为对于我扔回去的那一只来说，这很重要。”
So the point is, don't focus on the big picture, all right? Because if you do that, you'll get overwhelmed. That's just, you can't do that. What you can do is to focus on you, what you can do, what your values are, what your intentions are, how you will try to create a better world in the world that you can operate within. And so you bring that. But you're not, don't expect that you have got the power to produce a lot of changes because then you will get overwhelmed.
所以重点是，不要关注大局，好吗？因为如果你那样做，你会被淹没。那只是……你做不到。你能做的是专注于你自己，你能做什么，你的价值观是什么，你的意图是什么，你将如何尝试在你能够运作的世界中创造一个更美好的世界。所以你带来那个。但你不是……不要期望你有能力产生很多改变，因为那样你会被淹没。
Now, the other side of that is that we also worry for our children. And so what we then realize is that part of the anxiety is not for us. It's for our children and our grandchildren. And that's compassionate. How can I protect them from the potential horrors ahead? And that's a different issue of thinking about, how we can do that so so it's an important point this don't get overwhelmed by the problems because you're not going to be able to do that but what you can do is to focus on where you can do
现在，另一方面，我们也为我们的孩子担心。所以我们随后意识到，部分焦虑不是为了我们自己。它是为了我们的孩子和孙子孙女。那是同情心。我如何保护他们免受未来潜在的恐怖？这是一个关于思考我们如何能做到这一点的不同问题。所以这是一个重要的点：不要被问题淹没，因为你无法做到这一点，但你能做的是专注于你能做的地方，
and you know bring compassion to whatever you're doing and also thinking about what is your anxiety or probably your anxiety is mostly about your children and your grandchildren and your friends and therefore it's thinking about what how what would help me cope with the worries that I have about them yeah that is such important advice and even thinking about people working in perhaps NHS services that've got long waiting list is actually that starfish example is really powerful so yeah there might be multiple years wait to get into this service but actually I can do this assessment and do it really really well or the person that I find finally picked up off that waiting list, that matters because this person matters.
并且，你知道，把你所做的任何事情都带上同情心。还要思考你的焦虑是什么，或者你的焦虑可能主要是关于你的孩子、孙子孙女和朋友，因此，这是关于思考什么能帮助我应对我对他们的担忧。是的，这是非常重要的建议，甚至想到在NHS服务中工作的人，他们有很长的等待名单，实际上那个海星的例子真的很有力。所以，是的，进入这个服务可能需要等待多年，但实际上我可以进行这次评估，并且做得非常好，或者我最终从那个等待名单中挑选出来的那个人，这很重要，因为这个人很重要。
And I almost can't be too consumed with everything else that's waiting and all the people that I don't feel like I can help right now. Yes. I think that's really, really important. Focus on what you can do, not what you can't. And the other thing is that it's very easy to get caught up in anger. I used to get very angry in the NHS because I've seen how the underfunding of government after government, the callousness of government in relationship to health is just appalling.
我几乎不能被所有等待着的事情以及那些我觉得现在无法帮助的人所困扰。是的，我认为这非常非常重要。专注于你能做的事，而不是你不能做的事。另一件事是，人很容易陷入愤怒。我过去在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时经常感到非常愤怒，因为我看到了政府一届又一届的资金不足，以及政府在医疗关系上的冷酷无情，这简直令人震惊。
We're working with a group called Compassion in Politics, and they're working with young politicians and some of the young, on both sides of the house, actually, are beginning to talk about we do need to have more compassionate solutions to the problems that we're facing. the older folks, my age folks, they're a pain in the ass, but the younger ones are really getting the message that we need a much more compassionate society. It can't all be about checkbooks and accounts and money. And the health service is an example of extraordinary callousness at the level of politics. Extraordinary callousness is shocking really, but there we
我们正在与一个名为“政治中的同情心”（Compassion in Politics）的组织合作，他们正在与年轻的政治家们共事。事实上，议会两党的一些年轻人开始谈论我们需要为面临的问题提供更具同情心的解决方案。年长的人，像我这个年纪的人，他们真是让人头疼，但年轻人确实领悟到了我们需要一个更有同情心的社会。不能一切都只关乎支票簿、账目和金钱。医疗服务就是政治层面上极端冷酷的一个例子。这种极端的冷酷确实令人震惊，但事实就是这样。
are. People keep voting for them, so. But you can't get too caught up in personal, because and it just makes you very angry. Yeah, and I think when I was recruited to an 8A post, it was probably the anger and the indignance and the unfairness of it that actually drove me to be a really, really effective, efficient clinician. So in my first week, I'd been chatting to a member of staff, and I said, oh, have you been finding it, you know, the transition? It was kind of a remodeled service, and the clinician had said,
人们一直在投票给他们，所以……但你不能太纠结于个人，因为这只会让你非常愤怒。是的，我想当我被录用为8A级职位时，正是那种愤怒、愤慨和不公平感，促使我成为了一名非常、非常有效率的临床医生。所以在我入职的第一周，我曾与一名员工聊天，我说，哦，你觉得怎么样，你知道，这种过渡？那是一个经过重组的服务部门，那位临床医生说，
oh, I've been here about a year, and I've seen one client so far, And I was like, what, sorry, one client and the clinician said, yeah, because you know, you can't get the therapy rooms. And I said, oh, but I've been recruited to do a 50% face to face. And the client, the clinician had said, well, yeah, that won't happen because you can't get the rooms. And I was like, well, I'll show you. And so I was working four days at the time. And I ended up being a peripatetic clinician. I was in that base only for half a day. half a day a week when I would just do admin, but I found myself clinic rooms all over the rest of the trust. Ultimately, I ended up seeing clients in a private room, in a library, in a health
哦，我来这儿大约一年了，到目前为止只见过一个客户。我说，什么，抱歉，才一个客户？那位临床医生说，是啊，因为你知道，你根本找不到治疗室。我说，哦，但我被录用时说是50%的时间面对面工作。那位临床医生说，嗯，是的，那不会发生的，因为你找不到房间。我说，好吧，我会证明给你看。当时我每周工作四天。最终我成了一名流动临床医生。我每周只在那个基地待半天，那半天我只做行政工作，但我自己在整个信托机构的其他地方找到了诊室。最终，我在私人房间、图书馆、健康中心、社区免预约中心，以及一个有空房间的心理健康住院部见过客户。
center, in a, you know, community walk-in centre, in a mental health inpatient unit where they had a spare room. And I saw those clients and I got that waiting list down. So sometimes that can be helpful to activate our sense of drive. But it did ultimately lead to me, I think, burning out of that role, because if you're the only one that feels like you are doing those things and doing the work and seeing the things, it's, I find, I found it hard to, hard to continue that drive
我见到了那些客户，并把等待名单缩短了。所以有时这有助于激发我们的动力。但我认为这最终导致我在那个角色上精疲力竭，因为如果你是唯一一个觉得自己在做这些事、在工作、在处理这些问题的人，我发现很难继续保持那种动力，
without just feeling a little bit sad, Paul. Yes, and I mean, the key issue I think there is, why do other people feel disempowered to be able to do that? And we live in a society which subordinates people. They don't question authority. They don't fight back against the, you know, because capitalist societies and all of these, it's some people call it patriarchy of all.
而不感到一点悲伤，保罗。是的，我的意思是，我认为那里的关键问题是，为什么其他人感到无力做到这一点？我们生活在一个使人从属的社会中。他们不质疑权威。他们不反抗，你知道，因为资本主义社会以及所有这些，有些人称之为父权制。
And that it teaches people to be subordinate, don't question, right? Well, somebody like you and the whole reason you've got a podcast, all that is immense energy to kind of try to make a difference. So, you know, it's a very special kind of energy that. So, but not everybody has that. And so it's about how do we inspire other people who might be more fragile, who might be more shy, you might be more anxious, but oh, no, we can't do that.
它教导人们要顺从，不要质疑，对吧？嗯，像你这样的人，你做播客的全部原因，所有这些都是巨大的能量，试图去做出改变。所以，你知道，这是一种非常特殊的能量。但是并不是每个人都有这种能量。所以问题在于，我们如何激励那些可能更脆弱、更害羞、更焦虑的人，让他们觉得，哦，不，我们能做到。
How do we inspire them to be able to, you know, take the risks and have a go? I think it's really important. I mean, yeah, I mean, we had a dictate when I was in the NHS, I don't know, about 20 years ago. We all had to cut our budgets and all these managers came around and said, well, look, you know, you've got a part. the research and partly clinical department so we need to cut the budget so we're going to take your secretary away i said what are you talking about and they said well we just don't have any you know we've got to cut the thing i said are you serious are you going to take my secretary way so you'll pay me 40 pounds an hour to type a letter twice as slowly is my secretary
我们如何激励他们去冒险并尝试一下？我认为这非常重要。我的意思是，是的，我在NHS工作时曾接到过一个指令，大约20年前吧。我们都必须削减预算，所有的经理都跑来说，好吧，你看，你有一个研究部门和部分临床部门，所以我们需要削减预算，我们要把你的秘书调走。我说，你在说什么？他们说，好吧，我们没有办法，我们必须削减开支。我说，你是认真的吗？你要把我的秘书调走，然后付给我每小时40英镑，让我以秘书五分之一的速度打字？
could do it for five or whatever i mean it's ludicrous they're just mad uh all this payment by results we used to have a we used to run groups now these we used to run community groups and we'd bring in a group and we'd do some work with them for about 10 weeks particularly agrophobics and then we'd have another 10 come in and the ones that had been treated with partner up with the other ones and so we developed this fantastic community um of people and i'd keep an hour on them and if anybody was needed a little bit more help we would see that and so then the payment by results came in says they can't do that what do you mean it can't do that well it's not an effective therapy. What do you mean it's not an effect? We're keeping people out of hospital,
这太荒谬了，他们简直疯了。所有这些按结果付费的政策，我们过去常办小组，我们过去常办社区小组，我们会带进一个小组，和他们一起工作大约10周，特别是针对广场恐惧症患者，然后我们会有另外10个人进来，那些已经接受过治疗的人会与新来的人配对，于是我们建立了一个很棒的社区，我一直关注着他们，如果有人需要更多帮助，我们就会看到。然后按结果付费的政策出台了，说他们不能那样做。什么意思，不能那样做？好吧，这不是一种有效的疗法。什么意思，这不是有效的？我们正在让人们远离医院，
right? We're keeping people well. We're developing communities that is mutually supportive. Yeah, but it's not in the nice guidelines, is it? What are you talking about? I've got to do that. You've got to do recognize psychological therapies. Just madness. So used to get so annoyed talking to them about actually people are supported in their communities, right? And people feel valued and people paying attention to them and so on. And Julian Abel has done some fantastic, he's got a wonderful book called The Compassion Project, which he was a physician doing at the end of life.
对吧？我们让人们保持健康。我们正在建立相互支持的社区。是的，但那不在NICE（英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所）的指南里，不是吗？你在说什么？我必须那样做。你必须做公认的心理疗法。简直是疯了。所以我过去常因为和他们谈论人们在社区中得到支持、人们感到被重视、人们关注他们等等事情而感到非常恼火。朱利安·阿贝尔（Julian Abel）做了一些很棒的工作，他有一本很棒的书叫《同情心项目》（The Compassion Project），他曾是一名临终关怀医生。
And he's done some wonderful work about how you create compassionate communities that break into loneliness and have people talking together and de-shame and so on and so on. But yeah, it just, I mean, the NHS is nuts, basically, absolutely nuts. Yeah. Wonderful people and, you know, fantastic skills.
他做了一些很棒的工作，关于如何创造同情社区，打破孤独，让人们交谈，消除羞耻感等等。但是，是的，这简直……我的意思是，NHS基本上是疯了，绝对疯了。是的，有很棒的人，你知道，有很棒的技能。
The management and the funding of it is just nuts. There really are. I feel very privileged to have met the people I've met along my journey and, you know, either to keep them physically in my life or in my phone at the end of the phone, but also it's what we learn about people that just stays with us, I think, during our journey in psychology. It's such a privilege that I get to meet these people,
它的管理和资金简直是疯了。确实如此。我感到非常荣幸能在我的人生旅途中遇到我所遇到的人，你知道，要么让他们在现实生活中陪伴我，要么在电话里保持联系，但这也是我们从人们身上学到的东西，我认为在我们心理学的旅程中，这些东西会一直伴随着我们。能遇到这些人真是我的荣幸，
that we get to have an impact on each other and then I get to carry their wisdom with me as I will carry yours with me in going forwards. Like it's, we're really lucky. Yeah, but the key point you're making is don't get caught up in all that. Do what you can. Of course, you do what you can.
我们能对彼此产生影响，然后我能带着他们的智慧前行，就像我带着你的智慧前行一样。这真的很幸运。是的，但你提出的关键点是不要陷入这一切。做你能做的。当然，你做你能做的。
But if you get too caught up in it, then you will get burnt out because it is, it does make you very angry, quite understandably on behalf of the thing, but that anger in the end is a bit of a poison and it were under, you know, it's bad. So it's recognizing, look, I'll do what I can do and I'll do my best and that's it.
但如果你太纠结于此，你就会精疲力竭，因为它确实会让你非常愤怒，代表这件事感到愤怒是可以理解的，但这种愤怒最终是一种毒药，它……你知道，这不好。所以要认识到，看，我会做我能做的，我会尽我所能，就这样。
I can't do anything in that. And being able to come to terms with don't, I should be able, this should happen, that should happen, that should happen. If you get into all of that, then it just winds you up. So I always remember when I was young, I don't just qualified.
我对此无能为力。能够接受“我不应该这样”、“这应该发生”、“那应该发生”的想法。如果你陷入所有这些，那只会让你心烦意乱。所以我总是记得我年轻的时候，刚获得资格。
And I was working in an acute unit because I've always worked in the heavy end of the thing, as it were. And so I was beginning to see a lot of clients with quite severe abuse and goodness knows what. So I went to my supervisor. It was a lovely lady. She was psychedynamic. She passed away some years ago now. And in those days, you used to be able to smoke.
我在一个急性病房工作，因为我一直从事最繁重的工作。所以我开始看到很多遭受严重虐待的客户，天知道还有什么。所以我去找我的主管。她是一位可爱的女士。她是心理动力学派的。她几年前去世了。在那些日子里，你还可以抽烟。
And she used to love smoking these French cigarettes, car was. The room was full of smoke. And so I went to her and I said, Kitty, because that was her name. I said, look, I've got all these clients coming through now that I'm qualified. them being sent these referrals and they're really complicated and I don't know what I'm doing half the time. Surely they can see somebody else. And she said, well, who? I said, well, I don't know. There must be somebody. She said, no, there's only me and you. Were the only psychologists in the service in my list are full? So, oh no, what am I going to do? She said, so there must be
她喜欢抽这些法国香烟，卡瓦（Gauloises）。房间里烟雾缭绕。所以我去找她说，基蒂（Kitty），因为那是她的名字。我说，看，我现在有这么多客户，我已经获得资格了。他们被转诊过来，他们真的很复杂，我有一半时间不知道自己在做什么。难道他们不能看别人吗？她说，嗯，看谁？我说，嗯，我不知道。一定有别人。她说，不，只有我和你。我们是服务部门里唯一的心理学家，我的名单已经满了。所以，哦不，我该怎么办？她说，所以一定有
somebody else. She said, well, she said, I suppose we'd all be much better off if Freud was still here. But unfortunately, he's dead. So we're going to have to manage without him. And she said, look, the only thing you can do, you can be the best six-month qualified psychologist you can be. That's all you can be. You cannot be any more than that. You cannot give any more than that.
别人。她说，嗯，我想如果弗洛伊德还在，我们会好得多。但不幸的是，他去世了。所以我们必须在没有他的情况下设法应付。她说，看，你唯一能做的，就是做你作为一名有六个月经验的心理学家所能做到的最好。这就是你能做的一切。你不能比这更多。你不能付出更多。
In 20 years, you probably know a bit more than you do today. But right now, you don't know 20 years. You don't have 20 years experience. And that's try to be the best you can in this moment. That's it. There's nothing else, okay? Don't get caught up with anything else. Or the shoulds and blah, blah, blah, blah.
20年后，你可能会比今天知道得多一点。但现在，你不知道20年后的事。你没有20年的经验。所以试着在这一刻做到最好。就这样。没有别的了，好吗？不要被其他任何事情困扰。或者那些“应该”之类的东西。
just be what you can be. That's it. And, you know, if the world around you is burning, well, there's nothing that you can do about that. And so it was really good. She was lovely to me and really helped me on my way and help me to just ground myself and the doable and appreciate what I can do rather than always thinking what I can't do. And if only, and because you, you know, when you were a young therapist, you have all these thoughts, you know, or maybe if Beck was in the room or Freud was in the room or whoever maybe they'd see my incompetence and they'd wonder how the hell did I get to be a clinical psych all of those thoughts are coming to your head when you're new to the profession I don't know what the hell I'm
只要做你能做的。就这样。而且，你知道，如果周围的世界正在燃烧，嗯，你对此无能为力。所以这真的很好。她对我很好，真的帮助了我，帮助我脚踏实地，欣赏我能做的事情，而不是总是想着我不能做的事情。如果……而且因为你，你知道，当你是一名年轻的治疗师时，你有所有这些想法，你知道，或者也许如果贝克（Beck）在房间里，或者弗洛伊德在房间里，或者无论谁，也许他们会看到我的无能，他们会想，我到底是怎么成为临床心理学家的？当你刚入行时，所有这些想法都会涌入你的脑海。我有一半时间不知道自己在
doing half the time that's all natural it's okay don't worry about it just come bring yourself back to the moment okay so maybe in 20 years 30 years I'll be better than I am now but that's I'll have to wait absolutely And what a golden way to finish this 200th episode of the podcast. Like what wise and compassionate words actually. So I want to really thank you for your time. If people are interested in hearing more about our conversation, more generically about compassion,
做什么，这很自然，没关系，别担心，只要把自己带回到当下就好。好吧，也许在20年、30年后我会比现在更好，但那是我必须等待的。绝对是这样。这真是结束这第200期播客的绝佳方式。多么睿智和富有同情心的话语。所以我真的想感谢你抽出时间。如果人们有兴趣更多地了解我们的对话，更广泛地了解同情心，
they can tune into our second episode, which is coming up very soon. Thank you again for your time. in talking to my aspiring, our aspiring, psych audience, Paul. Yes, so that's great. So always try your best. Of course, you always try your best.
他们可以收听我们的第二集，很快就会播出。再次感谢你抽出时间与我那些有抱负的、我们的有抱负的心理学听众交谈，保罗。是的，那太棒了。所以总是尽你所能。当然，你总是尽你所能。
But that's it, there is no more. So the shoulds and the aughts, just be clear of that if you tried your best, that's good. Okay, thank you so much for your time, Paul. Thank you. Oh, what an absolute pleasure, what a privilege. I think my chat with Professor Paul will stay with me or forever, probably.
但就是这样，没有更多了。所以那些“应该”和“本该”，如果你尽力了，那就清楚这一点，这就很好。好的，非常感谢你的时间，保罗。谢谢。哦，这绝对是一种荣幸，一种特权。我想我和保罗教授的谈话可能会永远留在我的记忆中，大概吧。
You can hear it in my voice. You can see it if you're watching me on video. I loved that chat, and it meant a lot to me. Even reflecting on it now, you know. It's emotional. Like, I loved it. And I think if we all could take some learning from Professor Paul, we'd be kind of on ourselves.
你可以从我的声音中听出来。如果你在视频中看我，你也能看出来。我喜欢那次谈话，它对我意义重大。即使现在回想起来，你知道。这很感人。就像，我喜欢它。我想如果我们都能从保罗教授那里学到一些东西，我们会对自己好一点。
The world would be a better place. I would love your thoughts on this. Please do let me know in the comments. either on YouTube or if you're listening on Spotify or whatever you're accessing this content, let me know how it resonated for you. Let me know how it connected with you on what stage of career you are at. What will you take from this? What will be your take-home message? I would love to know. And why not listen to or read his books? I especially recommend the compassionate mind. That's a wonderful place to start. If you rate this content, please do subscribe to the
世界会变得更美好。我很想听听你对此的想法。请在评论中告诉我。无论是在YouTube上，还是如果你在Spotify上收听，或者无论你通过什么方式获取这些内容，请告诉我它如何引起了你的共鸣。告诉我它如何与你产生联系，你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段。你会从中带走什么？你的收获是什么？我很想知道。为什么不听听或读读他的书呢？我特别推荐《同情心思维》（The Compassion Mind）。那是一个很好的起点。如果你喜欢这些内容，请订阅
channel, please do follow the show wherever you listen to it. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any creator you rate. And in doing so, in building this audience, it helps me to get amazing guests like Professor Paul Gilbert. This is our 200th episode celebration. Thank you, whether you are brand new to the channel or whether you've listened right since the start. It means a great deal. I love doing what I do. I wouldn't still be doing it if I didn't, but I love to hear from you too. Please do come and connect with me on my socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere and share this episode far and wide because it just deserves to shine and to thank Paul for his time in speaking with us. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide with this podcast, that's your side, you'll be on your way to be in qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Mary and Trent. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate at Appalphillant.
频道，请在你收听节目的任何地方关注它。这真的是你能为你评价的任何创作者做的最友善的事情。通过这样做，建立这个听众群，它帮助我邀请到像保罗·吉尔伯特（Paul Gilbert）教授这样出色的嘉宾。这是我们第200期的庆祝活动。谢谢你，无论你是刚接触这个频道，还是从一开始就一直在收听。这意义重大。我喜欢做我所做的事情。如果我不喜欢，我就不会坚持到现在，但我也很乐意听到你的声音。请一定要在社交媒体上与我联系，我在那里到处都是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，并广泛分享这一集，因为它值得闪耀。感谢保罗抽出时间与我们交谈。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这个播客成为你的指南，有它在身边，你就会走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，来帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备。
And I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很高兴我买了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它让我对自己旅程和技能有了很多反思。它也有助于从长远角度看待问题，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，这本书最意想不到的乐趣是每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为动力真是太愉快了。我几乎不舍得读完它。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。